c'est une réelle immersion dans le monde
de l'enfance que nous propose le musée
de la ville de saint quentin en yvelines
objets et images d'archivés
photographies nous présente des aires de
jeux de la fin des années 60 à la fin
des années 70 c'est sans doute la
caractéristique de ces jeux par rapport
à aux jeux contemporains sont fondés sur
des formes relativement simple mais qui
incite beaucoup plus l'enfant un travail
d'imagination et l'appropriation
personnelle les pièces majeures
proviennent des espaces publics de jeu
de saint quentin en yvelines et ont été
pensés par plusieurs créateurs il ya
donc les voir ne sont les simonet est
aussi le groupe ludique c'est la
troisième pièce monumentale qu'on
présente dans l'exposition qu'on nomme
serpent qui a été réalisé par donc mart
et jean mary simonet qui sont donc des
des créateurs qui ont toute leur vie
travailler à la fois le matériau
plastique par par moulage et qui on
proposait des forme modulaire véritable
reflet de l'enfance dans ces années-là
ces jeux s'inscrivent dans une période
de l'histoire durant laquelle en donner
aux enfants une liberté beaucoup plus
grande les populations vont vers les
villes et les enfants de ces villes ont
besoin d'un espace créé récréatif donc
de jeu pour retrouver un petit peu dans
les espaces urbains ce qu'ils pouvaient
faire originalement dans les campagnes
c'est à dire grappes escalader se cacher
pour les vacances de la toussaint vous
pourrez également découvrir deux
activités au musée de la ville ville en
herbe le mercredi 27 octobre et
sculptures dans la ville le samedi 30
octobre